hey guys Jesus Christ here that's where
people let me call me lately because of
my facial hair Veronica because I have a
lot of facial hair lately my hair's been
getting big don't worry guys I'm going
to be cutting my hair and shaving rather
soon actually you'd be a very perverted
genius I'd be a very perverted Christ
Jesus Christ show you my nope not gonna
make a religious joke that I have like
all these horrible joke certainly do my
mind now that I can say is like awful
puns all right okay so I'm here today
basically because the Internet of
YouTube is getting more complicated for
me to keep up with comments and stuff
and through that I wanted to have a
request in regards to your guys's
requests basically if there's like
someone who didn't get a shout out yet
could you just comment below and like
let me know jeremyjahns people he's
another movie critic love that guy so
could you just comment below and just do
that for me and also if you have like a
I know a lot of guys have been a lot of
you guys have been requesting like
trailer reactions and I what happened
was my computer I had to do a reboot on
it and then I like two lost a lot of
information and I have like a list of
all these things so if you guys help me
out here if you have like requests can
you just put them all in the comment box
now so that way i can just look at one
video and go okay here's that way it's
much easier for me to just write out
again that would be very much
appreciated and I was one for you guys
to help me I would one thing too I
basically I wanted to know if you guys
could help me out a little bit there's
another youtuber out there her name is
roll credits you've seen her she's
really cool dude lets her actual name I
told her forgot it Natalie Adele you're
way off dude okay Adele alright so adele
is she's a movie
Nick her channels called roll credits
seriously she's an awesome youtuber like
I've actually been checking out her
channel a lot lately and I found out she
actually lives in LA I thought she live
in Australia cuz she's an Aussie that
was horrible of rebellion impression
I'll see ya if you guys can like check
out our videos and let go hey Ryan would
like it if you could be on his channel
for a few little videos something like
that nothing creepy you guys don't help
me out of the creepiest [ __ ] your ways
don't do it it's like hey go on rides
channel or else I'll [ __ ] murder you
like know that [ __ ] so yeah I got three
requests one could you put your shadow
request to the comment box to could you
put your car trailer request in the
comment box or videos whatever or
absolute cuz you guys recommend some
movies that are like available on
netflix i have a netflix account i never
use it or amazon prime and yeah i didn't
like to talk about that too so like if
you can recommend some the movies that
you know are there I don't want to rent
this [ __ ] already paid monthly for this
stuff okay third could you go to roll
credits and you really um you know
overwhelm her with requests to be on
this channel but she's really cute like
really cute like goddamn that's like the
main reason to meet her I was doing fine
wasn't I it was like hey he's kind of a
gentleman about this whole thing and
then I just totally lost it yeah [ __ ]
okay yeah hey Delia you're [ __ ] hot